اذا مشاهدينا من استوديوهاتنا في الرياض
الى دبي نكمل هذه التغطيه ان ميسون عزام
احييكم فجعه الزلزال في سوريا وتركيا تدخل
يومها الرابع حصيله الضحايا بارتفاع مستمر
تحديات جمه تواجه فرق الانقاذ التي تسابق
الزمن وجهود الاغاثه تدخل مرحله صعبه مع
تحولها من عمليه انقاذ الى عمليات انتشال
فاصواته الانيني بدات تختفي من تحت الركام
فيما تزيد بروده الطقس معاناه المنكوبين
على مدار الساعه العربيه تواكب معكم
التطورات لحظه بلحظه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الله يقويك يلا شد لي عزمتك
على الدرج بعدين سمعت صوتهم
للاولاد مصيف والله دورنا عليها جبناها
والله حتى صعب
[موسيقى]
زوجتي يعني اول شيء ربط بنتي عمرها اربع
سنين ونص ربطتها ونزلتها كان في شب من
جراعي بيستنى من تحت بس يفكر ربطه
انا كتير زعلان نغسلنا البيت
والالعاب والاغراض وكل شيء
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا ادعوا لنا نتحدث بالارقام نشاهد
على العواجل حصيله جديده لفاجعه الزلزال
تجاوزت اعداد الضحايا في سوريا وتركيا
18000 قتيل طبعا هناك ايضا ترجيحات تفيد
بان اعداد الضحايا اكثر من الارقام
المعلنه طبعا نظرا لوجود مناطق لم تصلها
بعد فرق الاغاثه في تركيا اعلن نائب
الرئيس ارتفاع حصيله الوفيات لتصل الى
و351 قتيل فيما تجاوزت اعداد الاصابات
ثلاثه وستين الف حاله في سوريا ارتفعت
اعداد الضحايا الى
356 بحسب اخر احصائيه للمرصد السوري لحقوق
الانسان
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا عدسه العربيه رصدت عمليات
الانقاذ التي تجريها فرق الخوذ البيضاء في
قريه بسنيه بريف ادلب تعون المتابعه
يا شباب
[موسيقى]
بس بس ما بتساوي
[تصفيق]
الناس في حاله زعر كلها تحت الركام مثل ما
نكون شايفين اجت هالشباب هاي الموجوده
كلياتها كتبت تساعدت ولكن بالاياديش يحصنه
يعني نحتاج نكاديرا ما حدا قصر بس هاي
امكانيات الشعب الموجود الله يكون بالعون
جايين جايين تطوع هون
يعني العالم ماسات الله اكبر
حجم الكارثه كبير وفي رقمها تقوم بالبحث
الى الان في قريه بثانيه على اخراج
العالقين تحت الانقاض
على كل المزيد معنا من القميش لمراسل
العربيه جمعه عكاشه اهلا بك جمعه ومعنا
ايضا من اضنه زيدان زينجلو مراسل العربيه
وابدا معك زيدان انقل لنا المشهد من عندك
واي معلومات جديده
نعم ميسون كما تتابعين
العمليات الانقاذ هنا في الخلفيه عمليات
الانقاذ ما تزال مستمره على قدم وساق في
سباق مع الزمن عسى ان يصلوا الى نتيجه
ايجابيه واخراج بعض الناجين حتى الان كنت
في حديث قبل دقائق فقط مع احد
خبراء او احد الطواقم الانقاذ الذي يصطحب
الكلاب المدربه الى هذا الموقع ويقوم
بالكشف والمعاينه اخبرني بان الكلاب
المدربه ما زالت تعطي حتى اللحظه اشارات
على وجود ناجين لذلك لم يفقدوا الامل وما
زالوا مستمرين رغم مضي او روما دخولنا او
انتصاف اليوم الرابع تقريبا بعد
بعد قليل ينتصف اليوم الرابع لحدوث هذه
الكارثه وبالتالي يعني رغم ان الامور
نظريا
تعني ان الفرص تتضاء لكن الفرق الانقاذ
هنا لا تعمل عن وفق هذا الاساس او وفق هذا
الاساس هم يحاولون البحث وكل الجهود او
عمل كل العمل مبني على وجود احياء حتى ان
السيارات الاسعاف تم استخدامها الى محيط
هذا المكان في حال خروج اي
ناجن ان شاء الله نتمنى ذلك ان يحدث قريبا
سيارات الاسعاف والاطقم الطبيه جاهزه
لتقديم اي خدمات طبيه او الخدمات الطبيه
العاجله ومن ثم نقلي الى المشافي القريبه
كما نتابع يعني العمليات تقريبا هذا
المبنى الضخم تم ازاله قسم كبير من الركام
وما زالت وما زالت تلك النقاط التي تشتبه
فرق الانقاذ لوجود عالقين تحتها تحاول
ازالتها برويه وبهدوء ودون استعجال حرصا
على سلامه الموجودين تحتها ان كانوا على
قيد الحياه
هل حتى اللحظه اعود اليك زيدان لنكمل هذه
النقطه ولكن دعني اسال جمعه ان كنا من حيث
يتواجدوا المعلومات المتوفره لديه لازلنا
نتحدث عن عمليات انقاذ ام اننا تحولنا الى
مرحله الحديث عن فقط عمليه اجلاء وانتشال
الجثث
ميسون لا تزال عمليات يعني البحث في
الامطار وفرق الانقاذ المستمره حتى هذه
اللحظه ولم تتوقف في اي مدينه منكوبه في
شمال غرب سوريا او حتى في مناطق الساحل
والداخل قبل يعني يومين انتهت الاعمال في
جبله اليوم لدينا معلومات مؤكده بان يعني
في حلب القسم الواقع
تم الانتهاء من رفع الانقاض في خمسين مبنى
في حلب بقيت اربع اربع مباني في هذه
المدينه لكن في جبله لا يزال العمل مستمر
اعداد القتلى وصل الى
في هذه المدينه الصغيره بينما في مناطق
يعني ريفه
حلب لا تزال الاعمال مستمره وتتركز بشكل
كبير الان في بلده
حيث يعني هناك سباق مع مع الزمن لانقاذ ما
يمكن انقاذه من اعلى تحت هذه الامطار
الى ما نشاهده الان على الشاشه مباشره
طبعا هنا صوره مركزه حول محاولات
للاستماع والانصات ان كان هناك من هو على
قيد الحياه وايضا لدينا صوره اخرى لا اعلم
ان كان بالامكان ان نظهرها على الشاشه ها
هي هي صوره طبعا
لمنطقه هاتاي وتظهر حجم الدمار الكامل في
تلك المنطقه رغم هذا الحجم ولكن كما نلاحظ
هناك تجمعات لرجال ورجالات الانقاذ في
محاوله لانقاذ ما يمكن انقاذه من تحت
الرماد على كل اكمل معك جمعه فيما يتعلق
بالوضع الان نتحدث عن ان هناك لاز عمليات
الانقاذ مستمره بالجانب التركي كنا نعلم
انه بعض المباني المتصدعه يتم هدمها من
قبل السلطات كيف هو الوضع من عندك
زيدان او لا
نعم نعم الان نحن في حاله صمت هناك اشتباه
بوجود ناجم كما تسمعي طلبوا استقام الكلاب
المدربه ايضا للتاكد لم يكن هناك رده فعل
الان دخل هذا الفريق شخص معه كلب مدرب
يذهب الى النقطه التي تطلبها فرق الانقاذ
للتاكد حاله الصمت بدات عندما انتقلت الى
زميل جمعه عكاش ونحن في حاله صمت انا اخفض
صوتي قليلا ميسون حتى نحترم الاجراءات
المتبعه في هذا المكان
ونبقي الصوره الان زيدان
نلتزم بسياسه الصمت ايضا نحن ساتحدث انا
سننقل الصوره مباشره ونبقيها على هذه
الزاويه حتى نشاهد استجلاب
للكلاب البوليسيه ربما في اشاره ايجابيه
عن ربما وجود من هو على قيد الحياه
ان المؤسسات الحكوميه والوزارات ستعمل على
اعاده اعمار المناطق المنكوبه خلال عام
قال ان الدوله ستقدم مبالغ نقديه للاسر
المتضرره طبعا لتخفيف عبء المالي اردوغان
اضاف ايضا انه سيتم محاسبه كل من يحاول
استغلال الكارثه للحصول على مكاسب سياسيه
والوزارات نبذل اقصى الجهود للمساعده
والمشاركه في عمليه البحث والانقاذ وهناك
عدد كبير من الموظفين الحكوميين هنا وكما
ذكرنا سابقا الهدف الاساسي هو اعاده اعمار
المدينه في اقصر وقت ممكن اي خلال عام
تقريبا سيتم اكمال اعاده بناء المباني
السكنيه والمدينه باكملها اما في هذه
المرحله سيتم تقديم عشره الاف ليره تركيه
كمساعده نقديه لكل اسره في المدن العشر
المنكوبه وهذه المبالغ ستساهم فقط في
تخفيف العبء المالي لكن مع الاسف نرى في
هذه الاثناء محاولات لاستغلال هذه الازمه
لمصالح سياسيه لكن نحن لن نسمح لهذه
الاستغلالات وسنحاسب كل من يفعلها
مشاهدينا ايضا نعود وننقل لكم هذه الصور
التي تردنا لحجم الدمار الكبير بمدينه
هاتاي طبعا جهود فرق الانقاذ متواصله هي
مدينه تعتبر الاكثر تضررا في تركيا من
الزلزال وعمليات انتشال العالقين تحت ركام
المباني المتهاويه مستمره فيما يفترش
الناجون الارض امالهم طبعا معلقه على نجاح
عمليات الانقاذ في اخراج احياء من تحت
الانقاض طبعا هذه صوره من
قهرمان منع مشاهدينا ننقلها لكم الان
ومحاوله
لانقاذ شخص عالق تحت الدمار طبعا الاماله
لا زالت عالقه حتى الان بان يتم النجاح
بالوصول الى من هم تحت الانقاد ويكون على
قيد الحياه لانه قبل كم ساعه من الان كانت
هناك عمليه ناجحه لانقاذ شخص من تحت
الركام وان كان عائلته كانت متوفيه وتم
انتشال الجثث الاخرى ولكن لازال الامل
موجود حتى الان هذه فرق الانقاذ تحاول
اخراج شخص الان او اشخاص ربما لا نعلم من
تحت الانقاذ في قهرمان مرعش وهذا ينطبق
على اكثر من منطقه ومن مكان شاهدنا قبل
قليل ايضا استجلاب للكلب البوليسي
لجس ان كان هناك بالفعل
التحرك ربما الذي شعروا به ان كان دليل
على وجود من هو على قيد الحياه تحت الركام
اذا صور مباشره من ق المرعش حيث تحاول فرق
الانقاذ اخراج اشخاص من تحت الانقاض من
هناك
نحن تتصدر قائمه المدن والولايات التركيه
الاكثر دمارا من جراء الزلزال هذا هو
المشهد هنا في هاتاي فرق الانقاذ تتوافد
وتعمل على مدار الساعه سابق الزمن بحثا عن
ناجين هنالك ايضا من يفترش الارض لانه فقد
بيته ولم يعد يمتلك اي شيء وهذه مساعدات
تاتي الى هنا تباعا من متبرعين ياتي
المحتاج وياخذ ما يريد من غذاء وطعام وحتى
البس
وهنالك ايضا في المقابل عمليات بحث تجري
على مدار الساعه في كل لحظه بحثا عن
ناجينا تحت الانقاض ومثال على هذا الذي
يحدث هنا في هاتاي ويتكرر في كل مكان هنا
ما يحدث في هذه البنايه حيث يتم البحث
الان بعمليه دقيقه وبطيئه عن شخص يعتقد
انه لا يزال على قيد الحياه تحت الانقاض
الامكانيات بس اخطاء من بسبب
انتشار الدمار في كل مكان في هذه الولايه
ولكن مع بدء اليوم الثالث للزلزال الا
تزال محاولات العثور على الناجين مستمره
لقناتي العربيه والحدث عمار الهندي هاتاي
[موسيقى]
كشف المرصد السوري لحقوق الانسان عن فيضان
نهر العاصي نتيجه فتح السدود ما تسبب
بنزوح اهالي المنطقه القريبه من مجرى
النهر مثل الحي الجمعيه في جسر الشغور
ايضا بعض المنازل في دركوش وقريه التلول
في ريف مدينه القين خوفا من الهزات
الارضيه الارتداديه حيث انكسر الساتر
الترابي في قريه التلول على نهر العاصي
مما تسبب بنزوح الاهالي الى القرى
المجاوره كما تصدع جسم سد ميدان كيف في
عفرين نتيجه الزلزال مما ينذر بكارثه ايضا
من جانبه اكد المبعوث الامميه الخاص
لسوريا بيترسون عن ضروره ايصال المساعدات
للمناطق المنكوبه اثر الزلزال شماليه غرب
سوريا وذلك باسرع الطرق وايضا بشكل فعال
الزلزال ضرب شمال غربي سوريا حيث كانت
الازمه الانسانيه تتفاقم بالاصل التقارير
الانسانيه تشير الى الحاجه الطارئه
للمساعدات اللوجستيه وفرق الانقاذ
والملاجئ نحتاج الى المساعده بشكل ملح في
اي مكان بغض النظر عن الحدود بشكل طارئ
وفوري وعبر اسرع الطرق واكثرها فعاليه
يجب عدم تاسيس الرد الطارئ على الوضع
الحالي والتركيز على المساعدات الطارئه
لمساعده الرجال والنساء والاطفال الناجين
والذين عانوا من اسوا زلزال في القرن يجب
وضع الناس كاولويه وان نعمل على هذا
المبدا
على كل المزيد معنا من الحدود التركيه
السوريه الصحفي ابراهيم الادلبي اهلا بك
دعني ابدا بما انتهى به المسؤول الغربي
يقول بانه يجب ان تصل المساعدات الى شمال
غرب سوريا باسرع الطرق ما هي اسرع الطرق
اهلا وسهلا بك وبجميع المشاهدين اسرع
الطرقيه
الطائرات الغازيه التي حطت في كل من مطار
انطاكيا ومطار اضنه وغازي عنتاب كل مطار
منها يمكن ان يسلك طريقا سريعا لدخول
الاراضي السوريه على سبيل المثال مفارقه
غازي عنتاب الذي يبعد قرابه الساعتين بعد
تحميل الشاحنات الاغاثيه يمكن الوصول الى
معبر باب السلامه من اجل ادخال المساعدات
او حتى الى معبر الراعي بالنسبه لكل من
انطاكيا واضنه تحتاج ايضا السيارات الى
قرابه الساعتين الى الثلاث ساعات في حال
كانت الطرق سالكه للوصول الى معبر باب
الهواء كما حدث منذ قليل دخلت قرابه عشرين
شاحنه من 20 شاحنه محمله بالمواد الاغاثيه
الاوليه للمتضررين من الزلزال من بينها
تسع شاحنات تحمل ماده الديزل لاردافها
لاليات الدفاع المدني والفرق المتطوعه
والاليات المختصه بازاله الانقاب لان هناك
كان تهديد حقيقي من توقف هذه الاليات سبب
نفاذ ماده الديزل انا عن ذلك بقي احد عشر
شاحنه هي ستوزع على المتضررين في المنطقه
التي ضربها الزلزال في شمال سوريا هذه
طبعا المساعدات بحسب مصادر داخل المعبر
اكدت انها لم تشمل
بالمساعدات العاجله التي وصلت الى
المطارات انما كانت ضمن بروسيسنج لاثقال
المساعدات ما قبل الزلزال وكانت قد علقت
على الطرق السريعه قبل معبر باب الهوى من
الطرف التركي وعندما تيسر الامر سمح بدخول
هذه الشاحنات طبعا المصادر الميدانيه
بالطرف التركي اكدت ان عمليه تسهيل دخول
الشاحنات لا يستغرق الا دقائق فقط بعد
تقديم الاوراق الاوراق الاعتماديه
للشاحنات يسمح لها بالدخول الى الاراضي
السوريه الى منطقه التفريغ في معبر باب
الهوى من الجانب السوري حيث كانت اداره
المعبر قد اعلنت بوقت سابق عن جاهزيتها
التامه لاستلام المواد الاراديه من اجل اع
وتوزيعه على المتضررين برفقه المنظمات
المختصه او المعنيه بهذا الامر بس سؤال
هذه الشاحنات ذكرت بانها كان من المفترض
ان تدخل
قبل الزلزال ما الذي اخرها اذا كانت
نعم نعم صحيح تاخرت بسبب انقطاع الطرق
جراء الزلزال الذي استهدف المنطقه
الجنوبيه من تركيا هناك بعض الطرق الغير
صالحه للتنقل وهذا هو احد الاسباب
المباشره للتاخر الوصول المساعدات التي
حطت في كل من المطارات التي ذكرتها
الكل كان يتحدث منذ
الزلزال من اول يوم وحتى الامس كنت اسمع
هذه الكلمات بانه كانت الجثث من تركيا تصل
الى سوريا كيف دخلت نعم صحيح الامر معقد
بالنسبه لسيارات الاسعاف او الطرق التي
يتم الحالات العاجله على سبيل المثال
سيارات الاسعاف التي لها الاولويه دائما
بشق الطرق على المستوى الحالات الانسانيه
بشق طرق فرعيه ترابيه او استخدام طرق
بالاساس هي غير صالحه للقياده ولكن يتم
استخدامها للمجازفه لايصال المصاب او
الجسامين الى ان كان الى منطقه معبر باب
الهواء او حتى الى النقاط الطبيه داخل
اراضي التركيه وحتى لا ايضا الامر امرهم
ذلك الامر في سوريا ايضا الاولويه دائما
تكون لسيارات الاسعاف ونقل المصابين لذلك
حتى لو كانت الطرق مقطعه او مهترئه يمكن
لسيارات الاسعاف على انطلاق عدد ترابيه
المعبده اما الان تو انه دخلت شاحنات وان
لم تكن مخصصه للمساعدات هذه ما بعد
الزلزال وانما من قبل الزلزال مساعدات
انسانيه هل يعني انه لم يعد هناك اي عذر
وان ما تبقى من شاحنات او ما سيرسل من
شاحنات هي قادره على الوصول
ضمن منطقه الاراضي الزراعيه او المخيمات
وهذا كان عائقا وتحدي بالنسبه لعبور هذه
الشاحنات الى الاراضي السوريه اي التصدع
نتحدث عن سدود عند نهر العاصي وانهيار
ربما البعض الاخر عنا معلومات مفصله عما
يحدث ومن له ان يساعد في اعاده الترميم او
ربما اتباع اجراءات وقائيه على الاقل
لحمايه السكان والمنطقه
دعيني ابدا من حيث انتهيت كان هناك منذ 48
ساعه مناشدات للمنطقتين الغربيه من ادلب
وايضا محيط منطقه ميدان كبيري في عفرين
بعد ارتفاع في منسوب المياه في المنطقه
الغربيه من ادلب بنهر العاصي تم مناشده
جميع السكان القاطنين على الضفاف نهر
العاصمه من مخيمات عشوائيه او القرى
والبلدات المحيطه بمحاوله الابتعاد عن
المنطقه قدر الامكان هو التوجه باتجاه
الحدود السوريه التركيه او باتجاه المناطق
المرتفعه خطط اعداد الضحايا من ارتفاع
منسوب المياه في نهر العاصي لان هناك اكثر
من سبعه الاف مدني كانوا قد نزحوا من تلك
المنطقه من ريف سلقين ريف جسر الشغور
باتجاه المناطق الاكثر وارتفاعا والاكثر
امانا لا اتحدث عن منشات سكنيه انما يتحدث
عن نقاط مخيمات عشوائيه او الاراضي
الزراعيه او حتى ايضا المخيمات على الحدود
السوريه التركيه اعداد عفوا نتحدث عن
ارقام التي خلفتها ارتفاع ارتفاع منسوب
المياه في نهر العاصي هناك اكثر من الف
منزل كان متصدع ساهمت هذه المياه بخروجهم
على الخدمه ووصولا الى احياء سلقين التي
غمرتها غمرت المياه الشوارع فيها واصبحت
غير قابله للاستخدام عبره الالات او عبره
المركبات التي كانت تستخدم بوقت سابق كما
تحدثت عبر قناتكما انها الات ايواء او
عربات ومؤقده بالنسبه للمتضررين من
فقام هذا الارتفاع وفاقم ارتفاع منسوب
المياه الاضرار الغربي ادلب الاعين الان
تتوجه باتجاه سد ميدانكي بعد ان سجل تصدع
في جسر السد وجسم اسد هناك ايضا تخوف في
حال انهار جسم السد سيكون هناك كارثه اخرى
لا تقل عن كارثه الزلزال في المنطقه
الشماليه من ريف حلب او تحديدا في منطقه
ريف عفرين ولكن حتى الان بعض المختصين
والفرق المختصه لا تزال تراقب منسوب
المياه ان كان في نهر العاصي او حتى في سد
ميدانكي تخوفا لاي كارثه قد تنزل في تلك
المنطقه لذلك المدنيون لحد هذه اللحظه
هناك استجابه عاليه ووعي كامل للمخاطر
المترتبه ما بعد زلزال من انهيارات او
فيضانات او حتى طوفانات من المياه طيب
عندما يتحدث المبعوث الامم الخاص لسوريا
ويقول انه من المهم وضروري ايصال
المساعدات للمناطق المنكوبه في شمال غرب
سوريا باسرع الطرق تحدثنا عن هذه النقطه
ولكنه يقول بشكل فعال عن ماذا يتحدث ولمن
يوجه هذه الكلمه عندما يتحدث بشكل فعال
فهو يوجه كلامه الى الحكومه حكومه دمشق
لان
الطائرات الوراثيه التي حطت منذ الساعات
الاولى مع مع الزلزال التي نزلت في كل من
مطار دمشق الدولي مطار حلب مطار اللاذقيه
هذه المساعدات التي قدمت من عدد من الدول
العربيه وايضا من روسيا لم يتم رصد او
تسجيل اي قافله توجهت باتجاه المناطق
المتضرره في شمال غرب سوريا كان هنا كانت
رسالته واضحه للنظام بالاشراف او بجعل بعض
المؤسسات التابعه للامم المتحده كالتالي
او منظمه الغذاء العالميه او حتى
منظمه الصحه العالميه التي لا تزال
مكاتبها تعمل بالعاصمه دمشق والهلال
الاحمر السوري ان يشرفوا على عمليه النقل
والتوزيع خاصه انه صد المناشدات على مدار
اليومين الماضيين من المناطق التي يسيطر
عليها النظام اللاذقيه وحماه وحلب بانهم
لم يتلقوا حتى الان مساعدات او لم تصلهم
الاراده التي وصلت الى المطارات التي
تحدثت عنها فهذا ايضا كان نوع من انواع
التوجيه المباشره او الانذار والمباشره
بحكومه دمشق في حال لم تقم بتوصيل
المساعدات او مراقبه وصولها بشكل سليم الى
المناطق المتضرره وهذا ما دفع الامم
المتحده وايضا مجلس الامن لتجديد اديه
العبور عبر الحدود وذلك بسبب عدم ثقتهم
بالنظام نحن لا نريد التحدث على الشق
السياسي بقدر
ما هو المسموع وما هو غير المسموح وايضا
قدره الامم المتحده على الضغط يعني عندما
نتحدث انه فريق الانقاذ او الطبي المصري
استطاع الدخول لمناطق سيطره المعارضه من
داخل مناطق سيطره النظام هل نقول انه
الطريقه الفعاله الامم المتحده قادره على
فرضها ام انه العلاقه المصريه
هي التي ادت الى ذلك التنسيق مع من وهل
نتامل ان يكون هناك من جنسيات اخرى ربما
او فرق اخرى مصريه ربما تنضم الى من دخل
اصلا
برايي الشخصي نعمل علاقه المصريه مع
دمشقيه التي ساهمت بدخول الفرق الانقاذ
بشكل سريع الى المنطقه لان النظام على مدى
اليومين الماضيين
رهن موضوعي نقل المساعدات الى المناطق
المتضرره تحت زريعه ازاله قانون قيصر او
تخفيف العقوبات ودائما ما كان الرد ياتي
من العنوان المتحده والمعنيين بهذا
الموضوع ان العقوبات لا علاقه لها
طيب يبدو اننا فقط عذرا تقطع الصوت
ابراهيم
التقطع الصوت كمل
كنت اتحدث على ان العلاقه اللي ما بين
الحكومه ما بين الحكومه المصريه ونظام
دمشق ساهم وسرع من دخول فرق الاراسه
المصريه الى منطقه جنديرس لانها فعلا كانت
منطقه منكوبه الامم المتحده كانت رسالتها
واضحه للنظام لا ترتهن العقوبات للمساعدات
الانسانيه والمساعدات الانسانيه هي شيء
مختلف كل الاختلاف عن قانون قيصر ان نتحدث
عن المساعدات الطبيه والمساعدات الاغاثيه
ولكن على مستوى ارسال الاموال هذا الامر
محظور ضمن قانون قيصر وهذا النظام الذي
اعطى وهذه هي النقطه نظام الذي يبحث عنها
وهي ازاله العقوبات على الايرادات الماليه
من اجل طبعا هنا هنا يكمن الاختلاف على
المستويات من الفرد على المستوى الانساني
والسياسي استغلال هذه المساعدات لترميم
المؤسسه العسكريه والامنيه او استخدام
الماليه او هذه الاموال لاعطائها الى
محتاجها لذلك تفضل الامم المتحده ان ترسل
مساعدات ملموسه اي مساعدات غذائيه
المساعدات التدفئه ومساعده الطبيه على
ارسال الاموال الى دمشق هذا الحال بالنسبه
لجميع القاطنين في المناطق المتضرره
عندما نتحدث عن مصر الجزائر علاقتها طيبه
مع النظام نعلم حين كانت القمه العربيه ما
كانت تحاول ان تفرده
لملا فراغ الكرسي السوري وان لم تكن قد
نجحت لديها فرق انقاذ لماذا لم تستطع
ادخالهم
هذا السؤال قد يجيب عليها الحكومه
الجزائريه اكثر مني ولكن
متابعتكم اكيد لديكم مصادر تعلمون من
خلالها ما الذي يدور على الاقل بهذا
الاطار او لا نعم قد تكون الفرق المختصه
التي قدمت من الجزائر او من البلدان
الاخرى لمساعده المناطق المتضرره في سوريا
نحن نتحدث عن كل المناطق في سوريا ليس
هناك تقسيم ما بين منطقه شماليه غربيه او
مناطق معارضه ومناطق نظام هي مناطق متضرره
يوجد فيها مدنيين سوريون على كافه البقاع
الوفد المصري او الفريق المصري اختار يبدو
انه اختار العمل بالمناطق الشماليه
الغربيه بسبب الحاجه الملحه ووصول
المناشدات للعمل في المناطق الاكثر تضررا
قد يكون الفريق الجزائري يعمل في مناطق
اخرى كل اللاذقيه او حماه لا امتلك
معلومات ليؤكد عن هذا الامر ولكن يبدو ان
هناك ايضا مناطق اخرى في تحت النظام هي
متضرره قد تكون به قدر حجم التضرر للمنطقه
الشماليه الغربيه والجميع يعمل بكل امكاني
من اجل مساعده المدنيين بعيدا عن اي تبعيه
للسيطره السياسيه او حتى العسكريه طبعا
لان اشير اسمح لي ان اشير الى العواجل
مرصد السوريه يتحدث عن ارتفاع حصيله قتل
الزلزال في سوريا الى
3,56 لاعلى ان كان هذا الرقم قريب او بعيد
عن ما ذكرناه في البدايه بدايه هذه النشره
عندما بدانا بالحديث عن هذه الارقام
كنا رقم نفسه على الاقل
356 اذا لا جديد هو نفس الرقم الذي اعلناه
في بدايه هذه النشره ولكن طبعا العديد من
المراقبين يتوقعون ان تكون الاعداد اكثر
مما هو معلن من الحدود التركيه السوريه
كان معنا الصحفي ابراهيم الادلبي شكرا
جزيلا لك
هذا هو اظهرت صور عبر الاقمار الصناعيه
نشرتها وكاله رويترز حجم الدمار الذي لحق
بمناطق واسعه جنوبيه تركيا وذلك من خلال
عمل مقارنه بين صور العمران والبناء
السكاني قبل وبعد الزلزال المدمر نتابع
[موسيقى]
وصلت البعثه السعوديه المشاركه في اغاثه
متضرري الزلزال الى مطار اضنه بتركيا حيث
كانت السعوديه اطلقت الجسر الجوي لاغاثه
المتضررين بطائرتين سعوديتين اتجهت فجر
اليوم الى مطار اضنه وهما محملتان
بمساعدات طبيه
واغاثيه وعلامتها ايضا فرق اسعاف وانقاذ
متخصصه واعلنت الحمله السعوديه لاغاثه
متضرري الزلزال مع تبرعات وصلت الى مئه
مليون ريال في اقل من 24 ساعه على كل مفرد
العربيه عبد المحسن الحربي معنى الان
مباشره من اضنه ليعطينا المزيد من
التفاصيل حول هذه البعثه تفضل
نعم ميسون بالفعل وصلت البعثه قبل ما
يقارب ثلاثه الى اربعه ساعات ومباشره
اتجهت لعقد اجتماعات مباشره مع الجهات
المسؤوله في تركيا وتحديد الافاد وهي
الجهه المسؤوله لتنظيم عمل الجهات
الاغاثيه حول العالم اجتماعات مركز الملك
سلمان مع هذه الجهه لديها العديد من
المواضيع والعلي ابرزها اين تذهب هذه
المساعدات السعوديه الفرق اللغاتيه
السعوديه اين تعمل تحديدا في المناطق
الاكثر تضررا وهنا تحديدا نتحدث عن مناطق
مختلفه في جنوب تركيا
لمساعده المتضررين من هذا الزلزال
بالاضافه الى كان هنالك حديث ايضا عن
كيفيه دخول هذه المساعدات الى الداخل
السوري وهنا نتحدث عن معابر التي يتم
اختياره لادخال المساعدات السعوديه ربما
خلال ساعات قليله من هذا اليوم ستدخل هذه
المساعدات بالاضافه الى ذلك هنالك الكبير
من قبل مركز ايضا استقطاب او استجلاب عدد
كبير من المعدات من السعوديه وهنا نتحدث
عن معدات التي تستخدم في البحث وتستخدم في
الدفاع المدني بشكل عام هنالك فريق كبير
جدا سياتي الى الى تركيا غدا من السعوديه
واكثر من 50 شخص من الدفاع المدني ومن
مختصين في عمليات الانقاذ وعمليات البحث
ايضا ميسون عند وصولنا مباشره الى هذه
المنطقه في اضنه وجدنا العديد من القصص
التي
التقينا باشخاص عاشوا هذه اللحظات لحظات
الصفر للزلزال وهم ايضا سعوديون التقيناهم
في هذه المنطقه وكانوا متواجدون في تلك
المنطقه ولعلنه ناخذ بعض هذه اللحظات التي
عاشها الاستاذ حمدان الشمري وهو كان
متواجد في المنطقه بالقرب او بقرب حدثنا
حمدان عن لحظات الصفر التي عشتها وانت
الان بعيد ومنزلك ايضا
اعتقد قلت لي انه تهدم بالكامل بسم الله
والصلاه والسلام على رسول الله اشكر قناه
العربيه على استضافتي الحمد لله والصلاه
والسلام على رسول الله انا تقريبا الساعه
4:14 كنت نيم بفراشي
فتفاجات انه جتني هزه ارضيه مع انه قبل 14
يوم حصلت هزه خفيفه وعاديه شوي
الكبته والدولاب طاح قدامي اول ما طاح
حملت نفسي طلعت نزلت مع الدرج بسرعه
وارتباك وكانت في احجار تطيح عليه
اضربي يمين ويسار
وزي الحلم يعني انا ما اول مره اعيش
التجربه فطلعت في الدور الخامس وما كان في
الاسانسير ما كان شغال المصعد ونزلت الحمد
لله اخر ثاني انا طلعت المدخل
المجمع اللي ساكن فيه طاح طلعت برا الناس
مرعوبه الناس ناس تصيح وناس يعني لا يعلم
الله لا يعلم الا الله بحالهم
فطلعت برا وجلست تقريبا من الساعه اربعه
وربع الين الساعه 8:00 الصبح
بالبرد ماني لابس الا شيء خفيف ولا اني
عارف شو بصير والناس جالسه تحذر انشقاقات
بالارض اصوات طلعن الظهر الحمد لله بعد
صارت هزه ثانيه واخف من اللي قبل
وجلست الين ما جت الساعه تقريبا الين
الليل عشت في الحديقه انا مع الاخوان
التركيه في العراق حمدان كل هذا في العراق
يعني لاني لابس شيء ولا في اي مساعدات ولا
في احد يقدر يوصل لنا بسبب الزلزال فجلست
الليله الثانيه مع الاخوان الاتراك في
الحدائق اي والله طبعا مطر وبرد وحاله ما
يعلم بالله الله انزل تهدم المنزل تهدم
والمنازل البقيه ولا في بيت قابل للسكن
يعني كامل المنطقه وحذرون انه ما احد يطلع
البيت خلوكم في الحدائق جلسنا بالحدائق
الين ثاني يوم ثاني يوم الحمد لله تواصلت
مع السفاره
وتواصلت مع محمد الحربي اي والله قال لي
تجيني بمكان التجمع اي والله جيت والحمد
لله ما قصروا وبيض الله وجيههم وبيض الله
وجيه حكومه خادم الحرمين الشريفين على
استضافتي وقاموا بعمل واجبي وانساني
والحمد لله جيت هنا وشفت النعمه وشفت
الراحه وشفت الطمانينه والوضع مستتم
ميسون هذا كما تشاهدين حمدان هو واحد من
القصص لعدد من السعوديين الذين تم اجلائهم
من المناطق تحدثت عن 45 سعودي تم اجلائهم
بالمناطق التي ضربها هذا الزلزال بالاضافه
الى تواجد ايضا بلاغ عن سيده سعوديه
متواجده في احد المباني التي انهدمت بشكل
كامل وهنالك تنسيق بين السلطات السعوديه
والتركيه حيال هذه السيده التي لم يتم
تاكيد حتى الان عن مدى
مدى تواجدها في هذا المكان او حتى عمليه
اج من هذا المكان والتاكد اصلا من تواجدها
ولكن البلاغ وصل من اهلها فبالتالي يتم
التعامل مع هذا البلاغ
متواجد للجميع عبد المحسن خبرنا الان كون
نتحدثنا عن عمل
السفاره على الارض فيما يتعلق
من هم من السعوديين متواجدين في تركيا
ماذا عن المساعدات وتفاصيل هذه المساعدات
وعندما نتحدث ايضا عن تبرعات تصل الى مئه
مليون ريال كيف
نشاهدها على ارض الواقع
دعم كل هذه المساعدات المليونيه
والاستجابه السريعه من قبل المقيمين
والمواطنين في السعوديه بهذا الرقم الكبير
نتحدث عن اكثر من مئه مليون هو سيتم
ترجمته مباشره
للمساعدات التي ستوصل الى تركيا عبر
الايوائيه المساعدات اللوائيه والغذائيه
والصحيه والطبيه وكل انواع المساعدات التي
بدات بالوصول اليوم وستبدا بالتوافد ايضا
الدفعات الاخرى بعبر هذا الجسر الجوي الذي
انطلق بدا من هذا اليوم حتى الى ما لا
نهايه نتحدث عن لا يوجد
رقم محدد لهذه الطائرات بناء على انه هذا
الرقم سيتحدث بشكل مستمر وفي ظل تواجد
ايضا مسؤوليه من مركز الملك سلمان ومختصين
الذين يقيمون الاوضاع والاحتياج ويقيمون
اجتماعات مع السلطات التركيه في حال زياده
في عدد الاحتياجات وفي حال طلبات معينه
هذا التنسيق حدث قبل ايام من الان منذ
وقوع الزلزال ترجمه على الواقع وجود عدد
كبير من المختصين في عمليات الاغاثه وايضا
الاسعافات شاهدت متخصصين في الدكاتره
سعوديين قدموا بشكل تطوعي الى هذه المنطقه
وهم مختصين بعمليات الانقاذ في هذه
الحالات الحرجه
للكوارث وكذلك هذا الزلزال فبالتالي
فبالتالي العمليه تتم وفق تنسيق متكامل
بين السلطات السعوديه والتركيه هذا
بالاضافه ايضا الى العمل على في الجانب
السوري هذه الحمله انطلقت بالتزامن بين
سوريا وتركيا وتحديدا كل الاماكن التي
ضربها فبالتالي التنسيق ايضا مع السلطات
او الاماكن الجهات الفاعله كما يتحدث
المسؤول مركز الملك سلمان
ومؤسسات الاغاثيه في داخل سوريا على تلبيه
هذه الطلبات بشكل عاجل قبل قليل استمعت
لاحد احاديث حول
المعابر التي سيتم ايصال هذه المساعدات
والتي ستصل خلال ساعات قليله قادمه الى
داخل السوري بالاضافه الى تواجد عدد كبير
من هذه المساعدات الايوائيه والطبيه
والغذائيه التي ستدخل الى اليوم بعد ان
وصلت الى مطعم
اللاحقه تفاصيل التحركات لهذه البعثه
السعوديه للانقاذ من اضنه موفد العربيه
عبد المحسن الحربي شكرا جزيلا لك
اعلنا متحدث البنتاجون باتريك رايدر عن
توجه حامله الطائرات جورج الموجوده في
البحر المتوسط نحو تركيا لتكون في موقع
يسمح لها بالعمل اذا طلبت انقره مساعده
اضافيه رايدر اوضح للصحفيين ان الولايات
المتحده تحاول ان تفعل كل ما في وسعها
للمساعده والاستجابه لطلبات تركيا مؤكدا
ان الوحدات الامريكيه المتمركزه في قاعده
انجليك الجويه في ولايه قونيا التركيه
بدات في نقل اول فرق الاستجابه الى
المناطق المتضرره من الزلزال
هذا وقالت منظمه القوه البيضاء ان عدد
الضحايا زلزال سوريا سيرتفع بشكل كبير
بسبب وجود مئات العائلات تحت الانقاض
المنظمه اكدت ان فرقها تواصل عمليات
الانقاذ وسط الظروف صعبه جدا بعد خمس
وسبعين ساعه على الزلزال كما كشفت ان عدد
الابنيه المنهاره كليا في شمال غرب سوريا
ارتفع الى
418 فيما تجاوز عدد الابنيه المنهاره
جزئيا حاجز الالف و 1300 مشيره الى ان
الاف المباني تصدعت بسبب الزلزال
استطاعت فرق الخوات البيضاء ان تصل الى
كافه المناطق المتضرره لازال العمل جاري
حتى الان لا اعلم من اين تاتي هذه الاخبار
لمعتب الامم المتحده ولا يوجد اي تواجد
حاليا للامم المتحده على الارض انا اؤكد
بوجود فريق الاخوان البيضاء بكافه المناطق
المنكوبه عبر شاشتكم لكل العالم ولكن
العمل لازال جاري وصل عدد الضحايا حتى
1900 بعد بعد عمل استمر لمده 72 ساعه
متواصله حاليا يعني نحن ننقل بعض الفرق من
بعض الاماكن التي استطعنا السيطره عليها
واستطعنا انتشال المصابين رجل تركي وعد
قبل ايام حفيدته بحضور حفل عيد ميلادها
واخفى عنها نوع الهديه التي ابتاعها لها
على ان تكون مفاجاه ساره لها لكن الزلزال
سبق موعد الحفل واطبق على الفتاه ووالدها
ووالدتها سقف البيت اما الجد فدخل في رحله
بحث عن من يساعده فقط لانتشال جثمينهم من
تحت الان لدفنهم ليرتاح تفاصيل القصه مع
مفرد العربيه الهطايا نحن في وسط مدينه
هاتاي حيث الدمار في كل مكان والبنايات
المدمره ومن هم تحت الانقاض والبحث جاري
عنهم هنالك من ياتي الى هنا وينتظر فقط ان
يحصل على جثمين من يخص من ذويه الذين
يتواجدون تحت الانقاض وهنا العم فقد علم
بان ابنه وزوجه ابنه حفيده قد رحلوا ولكنه
ينتظر حتى يحصل على جثامينهم ما الذي
حدثني لحرمه ابني مقشعه اما ابني وكانتي
ووالدي والده يعني وين موجودين الان هون
قريب منا نبري من هون تعال نمشي انا وياك
عشان تحكيلي تفرجيني كيف كيف متى تلقيت
خبر وفاته انت تاكدت انهم توفوا
بكير لابني بالتليفون او ما يعطي الجواب
بس انا ابني مهزوم لبره والتلفون جوا
بعدهن الولد التلفون من اسطنبول قال
القرميت طير يا ابوها عن الابرتمان لا
تروح الدروبه مسكره بعدها ما حملني قلبي
ولدت
عمل لي تلفون قال لي اياه خيي هو تحت
الجسم لا تقول قلت له اختك هيك ما تقول
قال والله يا بيي انا حملت حالي
وبنته يعني انتم تاكدتوا منه انهم رحلوا
توفوا توفوا توفوا معهد ما نقدر نشيلهم ما
حد ما يستجري يقرب لكن انت بدك جثامينهم
تنتظر جتامين
هون هون خليه بس عشان اشرح لنا وين المبنى
اللي فيه
والله انا بنتي يوم الحد العصر الاحد عملت
لي التلفون يا جدي يا ددا ايش تعمل قلت
لها انا كتير كيس انت ايش قال يا جدي انا
يوم فلان الي ميلاد بيوم الخلق عيد
ميلادها عيد ميلاد بدك تجيني قلت
اما بدي يجيكي بشغله ايش قال يا داده ايش
يا جدي شو هالشغله قلت لها ما بقول لك
بدي فريق هيبه يوم الميلادك ايش بتجيب لي
قلت لك اما انا محضر لحلق في دانا
الحلق وببكي وهلق اكشات تمورطه حط
خارجياتها جواتها وعيبت فيها للولد قشطه
وامها نايمه نصها باينه اما امرض تحت
الجسر والغطه حشاد قامت ايش بدي اعمل انا
ما اعرف نعزيكم نعزيكم بما رحم
الله يديمكم القناتي العربيه والحدث عمار
الهندي هاتاي
قصه حزينه من ضمن قصص اخرى حزينه من سرمدا
بشمال سوريا ينضم الينا احمد يازجي عضو
بهيئه الدفاع المدني في ادلب السوريه اهلا
بيك احمد استمعنا الى هذه القصه الحزينه
ولا شك انه في ذهنك الكثير من القصص
العالقه
احمد هل تسمعني
انا اسف تمام هيك تفضل هل سمعت ما ذكرت
انا ولا لا
تمام هلا بالنسبه للقصص خلال يومين
الماضيين يوميا كنا نشهد الاف القصص والاف
المعاناه
خلال عمليات استخراج نادي للاطفال
والاهالي الموجودين تحت الانصاب قصص
لا يمكن وصفها قصص صعبه قصص حتى كنا نكلم
الاشخاص الموجودين تحت الانقاض يكلمونا
نكلمهم
يصفون ما يشاهدون الان
بجانبهم ان كان احد افراد اسرتهم المتوفين
او حتى على قيد الحياه مئات القصص التي
كنا نشاهدها يوميا وخصوصا في المباني التي
كانت معده للنازحين كانوا يعطونها
النازحين الموجودين والذين الى حد هذه
اللحظه تعمل فرقنا على عمليات استخراج
هؤلاء
المدني الموجودين
لديك قصه تشاركنا فيها ولكن عندي سؤال
يتعلق
بالمرحله التي وصلنا اليها الان في تركيا
لازال هناك اتباع لسياسه الصمت على امل ان
يتم الوصول الى احد الناجين ماذا عنكم وهل
من المنطق الانتظار الان وتوقع ان يكون
هناك ناجم
نحن على امل ان يكون هناك نادين بالامس في
ساعات بالليل المتاخره خرج طفل على قيد
الحياه الساعات الماضيه من خلال ساعات
الصباح الى الان
اخرجنا عده اشخاص من تحت الانقاذ ولكن
للاسف كانوا قد فاقدين الحياه ناسف لوقوع
لازدياد عدد الضحايا بسبب التاخر او بسبب
نقص المعدات والمستلزمات لدينا كفرات قطاع
مدني
وصل الان العدد الضحايا الى
1990 بالاضافه الى 2950 دريع فعدد قابل
للزياد ولكن للاسف هو عدد قابل للزياده
الضحايا وليس لعدد لاستقبال المصابين ناسف
ان نقول لان السعاده القانونيه هي ساعات
حرجه
اسف بصوره عامه او انه فعلا الضغط الذي
تواجهونه كرجال انقاذ يدفعكم للشعور بتحمل
المسؤوليه
نحن كدفاع مدني
نحن كاشخاص كافراد الطاقه موجوده افراد
بشريه موجوده مدربين افضل تدريب لدينا
خبرات الخبرات سابقه خلال القصف النظام
الروسي والسوري على المدن السوريه وتهديد
من المباني مسكنت فرق الدفاع المدني من
خبرات لم يمتلكها اي فريق اخر على مستوى
حتى على مستوى العالم انت تعملين ضمن
الظروف لا يمكن لاي فريق في العالم ان
يعمل بهذه الظروف وكانت لدينا الاراده كان
لدينا هذه الروح لعمليه انقاذ هؤلاء
المدنيين العالقين تحت الانقاض في ظل
طبيعه جغرافيه تدميريه كبيره جدا كانت على
مستوى شمال سوريا المحرر بالكامل وليس على
امتداد معين
[موسيقى]
نحن موجودين بس ولكن كانت هذه
المعدات المتطوره
المعدات الحديثه حتى المعدات التي
نعمل بها حتى الاليات كانت يعني غير كافيه
عاملنا على اطلاق نداءات للمجتمع المدني
والمجتمع المحلي للاستمرار ايضا بتعمل
تواطنه وحتى الالياته للاستفاده منهم
عملنا جميعا تكاثفنا جميعا لانقاذ اكبر
عدد من المدنيين لكن للاسف كان هناك
معوقات في معوقات كثيره بس عندي سؤال فيما
يتعلق بالجانب النفسي لانه الكل متعرض
للضغوط ان كان منهم تحت الانقاذ لا زالوا
على قيد الحياه وحتى بالنسبه للاهالي
وايضا حتى بالنسبه للعاملين رجال الانقاذ
في دعم نفسي لكم او لا
الدعم النفسي بصراحه ان احنا بنتلقاه لما
بنخرج شخص على قيد الحياه والله بوصف لك
شعوره انا كنت خلال يومين ماضيين في احدى
عمليات الانتسال عائله كامله من ثلاث
اطفال وامراه وزوجها هم على قيد الحياه
شعور عندما كان النداء جميع الناس
الموجودين بالفرحه هذا الشعور الذي يعطينا
حافز للاستمراريه يعطينا شعور ان نكون
مستمرين في عملنا يعطينا شعور ممتد ان
نقدم
نواصل الليل بالنهر والله هلا اذا بدنا
نحكي الفرق الموجوده عنا وصلت الليل
بالنهار ما بعرف فريق انا مستحيل كان نقطه
معينه طريق انه لا ما تاخر او فريق مثلا
مناوب غير فريق فكان المواصلات الليل
بالنهار لعمليه الانقاذ كنا نحن نسعى انه
نخرج هذول اخ العالقين الموجودين هن
بيعرفوا شو يعني الدفاع المدني وشو
امكانياته لحتى يجي يساعدنا بس نحن انه
كانت امكانياتنا اكبر من اصغر من هاي
الكارثه الكبير عندي سؤال معظم من هم على
قيد الحياه عندهم اصابات بليغه او لا
يوجد عده اصابات بالاضافه يوجد كسور مشاكل
بالضبط المشافي العامله في الشمال المحرر
بعض
السيارات الاسعاف كمان كانت هي عباره عن
مسافه متنقله لزياد عدد المصابين في
المشافي المتوزعه في كمال سوريا وللعلم ان
هذه الاونه الاخيره كان هناك نقص حاد في
التمويل لدى المشافي فكان
الزلزال والضغط عليها من سرمدا بشمال
سوريا احمد يازجي عضو بهيئه الدفاع المدني
في ادلب السوريه نتمنى لك السلامه ولجميع
وشكرا جزيلا لك على هذه المعلومات التي
قدمتها وطبعا مشاهدينا التغطيه مستمره على
شاشه العربيه ولكن هذه الساعه حتى الان
انتهت ونلتقي في الخامسه مشاهدينا نعود
الان الى استوديوهاتنا في الرياض ومعنا من
هناك خالد